if you can lever other organizations to
feed your pipeline
and you can scale it so that has impact
then you've really done something well
[Music]
laura louder thank you so much for being
on my show how are you
thank you michael it's a pleasure to be
here i am incredibly excited for this
because i've heard so much about you
i've worked with you through j ventures
i've seen you
you know being the chair of the
adventures and reading about all the
different incredible things that you've
done
it's inspiring and the impact that
you're having hands on is just
is just remarkable and i would love to
spend these 20 minutes
to talk about your journey i want to
talk about philanthropy i want to talk
about
philanthropic venture capital i want to
talk about you know
your work with j ventures and the
different you know jewish
organizations here and what that means
to you but first of all
laura right before we started this you
mentioned sports that sports guide you
into this competitive nature which is
very
er which is very evident also in the
space that you're in today so talk to me
a little bit about this
passion for sports and how you get
started
great okay michael well thanks so much
for doing these i i think these podcasts
are just
so relevant it gives you folks an
insight into
how people got to the place that they
are i mean i'm pushing 60 here and
even though you can't tell by my hair
color i love the
i love the fact that that uh i i used to
be a young person and always looked up
to folks who
have done much more and so it's
wonderful that you're you're doing this
thank you very much i appreciate it so
so in terms of
of of how i grew up uh the reality is
that i grew up in a small town in ohio
midwest
my father was involved in uh in
international business and so he was
gone a lot of the time
but he used to bring me back wonderful
toys and wonderful
uh cultural um gifts
from from his travels and one of the
things that he was also very passionate
about
was tennis and so as a as a child
growing up
i was always very very enthusiastic
about
beating dad in order to uh
show him that he had a great kid to come
home to whenever he came
back from these travels and as a result
i became a competitive tennis player
i'll never forget when i was 16.
i actually i i actually challenged my
dad
to uh to a big match he had been playing
all his life and i was very very
passionate about tennis
and i challenged him for the big match
and what was going to be the reward
a new used car for me so i could drive
myself to tennis tournaments
and that imbued a whole passion for for
being competitive
and then once i won that car from him
because
because i definitely beat him you could
probably have guessed that
i ended up playing college tennis and
college tennis was a very different
experience because i was so much focused
on
individual competitions but now playing
as a team
that collaborative spirit and yet we
were as a team competitive against other
schools
that made me a much better let's just
say
partner and teammate in in in the
greater world
so sports has always provided a way for
me not only to stay healthy and fed and
hopefully not look too much like i'm
pushing 60 but
but definitely a way of life and and a
way to collaborate with others
in this competitive world i love it so
what was it
what is it about this competitive nature
in this collaborative world because
you know i i took part in in first
robotics uh
robotics competition back in israel but
also in the us and one of the wonderful
things that that dean came in there the
founder of it
it says is cooperation cooperation and
competition
which resonates a lot to what you're
saying here about you know your
experience with tennis and now into this
other world
what is it about this cooperation that
you find useful
in your journey today so michael one of
the things that that i found is that
as a philanthropist when i married gary
lotter and i realized i was moving into
a new world of philanthropy
i'd always been passionate about
philanthropy but i was i had a career in
tech
and and and i was a salesperson for an
ibm mainframe
software company 370 architecture wow
cobalt code generators and that whole
world in the 80s once i moved out of
that and married gary when i was 30 i
realized that i had to step
up my my game in the philanthropy world
because that was going to be my my new
future
um you know gary and i like to like to
joke that he
now as a venture capitalist likes to
make money and i try to give it away and
i'm faster
so so what i try to do is
try to use our philanthropy to file to
fill gaps
where there where there's no one else
perhaps
focused in this area and our added value
is going to really make the difference
it's going to bridge
where people are today to what a future
could look like
now in order to do that that's a highly
competitive space
because you have to collaborate with the
people on one hand
and then hand off to the other hand so
for example
um here's a an example our children were
going to a jewish day school
and at that jewish day school they had
the most wonderful teachers
the gideon house and jewish day school
in palo alto california
but what i realized is that these kinds
of teachers weren't
weren't duriger they you didn't see
fantastic teachers like these in
all schools so i said we've got to find
a way to to build a pipeline
of jewish teachers who are passionate
about teaching
and passionate about tikkun alum and
passionate about
integrating jewish values into the
curriculum so
there was this big gap of a pipeline of
jewish day school teachers so i created
this program called delete
which as you know is hebrew for door it
was opening the door to
a to a career in teaching and we
have now trained hundreds and hundreds
of jewish day school teachers
sort of like a jewish teach for america
and and that never existed before
but we had to collaborate with all of
the schools because they had to tell us
what the criteria were for the best
teachers
we had to collaborate with the
universities that were training teachers
we had to collaborate with any number of
different organizations that were
feeders into our program
but we had to make ourselves the best in
terms of
excellence and standards so that we
could scale this
because the most the two most important
words in philanthropy
are leverage and scale if you can lever
other organizations to feed your
pipeline
and you can scale it so that it has
impact
then you've really done something well
that is exactly what i'm curious about
because you know before when you're
saying that
you know spending money that's that
doesn't do justice to what you're doing
you're you're using
resources to make a lasting impact on
people and i'm really curious about this
this latter part this lasting impact and
how do you actually use
resources to go and transform
institutions
you know different industries and
different people's lives so that they
can pay it forward and then
transform others people other people's
lives so how do you do that at scale
because sometimes it seems that a lot of
the endeavors that
people do in philanthropy they're
short-lived or they are very specific to
one
segment how do you go about
strategically thinking how do i take
something like
that and make it at scale so that every
one of those teachers can influence
another teacher
and dozens of students who will then
grow up to be educators themselves and
mentors themselves
exactly well you've said it about delete
so i'll give you another example
so uh so our our kids both were thinking
about doing a gap year
both before college or after college and
when we really thought about
what are the impacts that young people
can make a lot of folks say
you know somebody 18 years old what
really what benefit can they provide to
the world in terms of really doing
something impactful
well when you talk about scale then you
can think about what
what israel does which is fantastic in
terms of
enabling young people to do a gap year
before they join the army
and it's a service year i did that as
well yeah
not a service here but i did a different
gap year right
so in the united states we have
something called americorps
only 80 000 young people are eligible to
do americorps in terms of the funding
that by the federal government at 25 000
per kid there are 600 000
applicants so a group of us at the aspen
institute worked with
four-star general stanley mcchrystal who
desperately wanted to create
a national program with huge scale so
that
there are now a million young people
serving in the in the in the military in
the united states
he wanted to see a million young people
serving their country doing national
service
and right now we're at 80 000. but the
demand is there
so how can we scale that up so a group
of us started a a wonderful new program
called
the service year alliance and we
collaborated with all
kinds of nonprofits across the country
and we're working to try to enable
every young person who wants to do a
service here to be able to do that at
age
18 to 26 and just this week
we have introduced legislation into the
united states senate co-sponsored by
eight democrats and eight republicans
called the corps
act c-o-r-p-s and that piece of
legislation we're hoping to include into
that the the republicans version of the
covid relief act
and that would enable 250 000 young
people
to do a year of national service so
scale
is absolutely critical and at the end of
the day public-private partnerships
are the best way to do that and what it
sounds to me from that story it's not
just about the resources it's about the
relationships and it's about
the strategic entrepreneurial mindset of
how do we get
from 80 000 to 250 000 with the
collaboration from different
organizations around the us showing that
there's a product market fit right you
have
600 000 applicants who want to do this
this is not just the dream that you're
selling somebody on
this is a reality that is just there's a
bottleneck that you have to turn the
switch
and make that happen and there's a
matching component so it's very
very much a tech platform so if you go
on to the service your alliance website
serviceyour.org you'll see that you
could put in criteria
i want to teach fifth grade in new
orleans starting in september of 2021
and a list of opportunities will come up
and you can apply to them directly
through the website making it super easy
for young people to apply to these
service positions
is really the key to making it
successful wonderful laura talk to me a
little bit about
your jewish identity and why are you so
excited and passionate about this
both your jewish identity but also
looking at it
a bit broader putting together the
israeli identity and the jewish identity
and the different groups
and what's happening here in the us and
the bay area obviously you know we're
seeing the rise of anti-semitism
around the world which is horrifying and
i believe just last week we had
swastikas and stanford campus
so so it's all around us always and and
you're very very involved with with your
jewish identity in the jewish community
so i'd love to get a little bit of
inspiration into that
also you know myself as an israeli and a
jewish citizen here in the bay area
with all my family back in israel
great question michael um you know in
the united states
you have to choose to be jewish today
people can assimilate and not
be involved when you live in israel and
grew up in israel it's just part of life
and and it's part of your identity that
in in in ways that sometimes
is negative because there are so many
ultra orthodox the hare redeem
destroy a lot of the culture of of
of of what is what is really
authentically jewish i think
right so so my sense of of of judaism
is this positive joyful values-based
identity that i hope
i got from my parents and i hope to be
teaching now to my children
and what i would say to you is that
raising kids
is a very difficult thing to do and when
you have a framework
of values that enable you to to teach
them
not only by the texts that are ancient
but also by the deeds the mitzvot
that you do every day so that kids learn
by example
that to me is the framework of what
judaism provides
that is so valuable to me it's the
history the tradition
the values the culture the land the
language
it's all of these things together and
and so as a result of that
i have gotten very involved in jewish
life ever since i was very young so i
mentioned that i was a tennis player
my very first experience in israel was
teaching at the israel tennis center in
rahmatan
i trained there no kidding i'm a tennis
player myself
yes oh wonderful you're for your feet
well we we loved playing tennis at the
israel tennis center and then by the
time my kids were old enough
our son was a big tennis player our
daughter played some too
that was one of the places that we took
them on on our son's bar mitzvah trip
so that they could play tennis with
israeli teens and
and and and and folks who weren't just
jewish
i mean they're as you know there are
arab israelis who also play
in the 13 or 14 different israel tennis
centers around the country
and the values associated with teaching
kids to play tennis
learning the values of hard work and
discipline and practice
and then also the tutoring piece which
as you know also happens at the israel
tennis center
and then countries around the world came
to israel to say how did you create
this wonderful tennis program that
enables kids to learn from each other
and also integrates the communities
together
who cares if you're from an arab
community or a jewish community or a
you know a a bedouin community tennis is
tennis
and on the court everybody has to be a
team player and has to be
a good competitor so i i just love the
values that judaism has created
and it puts it into play and into work
in israel
i love it i love it laura how do you how
do you manage your time you're doing so
many different things
you know just reading just you know
preparing for this and reading
on all the different sources it's
overwhelming the number of things that
you've done
you know very involved also with npr on
their board
how do you manage your time at the end
because you have so much
to give right you have so many different
passions and ideas
and we were transitioning from from
sports to
uh to americorps to to judaism how do
you
balance your time so that you can both
provide impact to these organizations
who need your time
because at the end the people are
looking at you as a leader at the same
time allowing yourself to branch out and
take risks on other endeavors
and continue to evolve and scale
well first and foremost i have to give a
lot of credit to my sweet husband gary
who
just supports me in every way possible
so um and and then secondarily to our
two kids josh and eliana who
went to the gideon housing jewish day
school have great values and
are are living really positive
impact lives right now and and as a
result of the fact that i have
really afford very very fortunate to
have a healthy family
both physically as well as emotionally
yeah they
are are a great support system we are a
great support system for each other so
that
is the core and and family values of of
our
core family is really critical the
second thing i would say to you is um
living a healthy lifestyle like i am now
a crazy maniac biker um i i love biking
with a lot of israelis because they're
very
uh competitive and so i i bike a lot
with zach renatt i don't know if you
know that but zach and i just actually
biked for a week here in aspen colorado
last week and uh he put me to shame so
i'm
trying trying to keep up with zach and
orly but
i would also say to you that managing
your time
in terms of making sure that you're
you're focusing on your priorities
that is the critical element i don't
frankly i hate to say it i have not seen
a television show and i don't know how
long
we have dinners with friends outside
during this coronavirus pandemic
almost every every single night so we're
we're connecting with people we're
hearing their ideas we're keeping this
balance of life with
with exercise with friends with family
and and of course with our passions so
i'm on 11 boards
and these boards are are very time
consuming my most recent board is the
national constitution center in
philadelphia
which which educates the world about the
con the american constitution what are
a critical civics education today it's
it's so important
but i can't get especially today
especially today
but i can't get involved in any of these
things unless i really have balance in
my life
there's there's one other really
wonderful initiative that i've just
taken on
and um and it's an initiative that i
that that uh odette and i have created
it's called and which means the
guardians
yeah and this is a pro publica for
israel
so this is an opportunity for us to
provide
philanthropic journalism at its best
investigative journalism
providing the best of news stories to
the existing media
on social issues not about politics not
about the military
not about the conflict it's about the
social issues that are at play today in
israel
and i love israel so much that i want to
make sure that israel is the best it can
possibly be
and i think investigative journalism
helps a country
become the best it can be so among all
of those things
i can't pick one favorite it's this it's
all my baby
it's the the passionate suits from the
screen and lastly
you know we have to talk about j
ventures and that i've gotten involved
with as well and i've
and and you know i've been so inspired
by by odette and the team there
and really the community that is being
built so i've you know i've gotten to
know especially through this show
a lot of different vcs and i can very
you know honestly and genuinely say
i've never seen a community as strong
and as
genuine as jay ventures especially going
into due diligences with you know
10 lps who are each incredibly busy
and working together because we enjoy
working together checking the ego at the
door as small
said i said on the show he's also an lp
there and you're the chair of chair of j
ventures and one of the missions is to
connect
the the jewish and israeli community
together and to create some
and create magic there now we're both
working on the next generation project
for for young israelis and jewish so so
talk to me a little bit about your
involvement with the j ventures and why
why that fund and what are we trying to
do there
sure so so let me just correct you one
thing michael i'm not the chair of jay
ventures that's a dead and jim kashlin
what i'm the chair of is this community
outreach element so the philanthropic
piece of it so
so as we begin to have exits and we have
some uh
some philanthropic capital then to to uh
to to put into play
we now want to encourage the next
generation of j ventures to participate
in everything that we're doing so that's
the objective there right
but the reason why i was involved with
odette at the very beginning to help
help him create j ventures was really to
to to bring our passions together in
into one community to integrate
folks to give them opportunities to meet
others can you imagine there are
many american jews who don't know
israelis
in in in an intimate way to know how
what are the issues that they have faced
as as as young people growing up in
israel or young people growing up here
with an israeli identity
so we share this this zionism passion
but we also share this
this this this legacy of judaism and
of those values that i i dare say
some israelis don't value as much as
american jews do
and so he's seeing the passion for
tikkun alum of american jews and the
passion for
for for creating community based on
judaism
that's kind of a rare thing for some
israelis and so
to bring these two communities together
to share their common purpose and
passions
i think is a really worthwhile endeavor
i love it laura
for myself and for other young
entrepreneurs and engineers going
through their journey
you know what what should we keep in
mind as we go along for the next for for
our you know our futures
whether it would be in tech or education
or whatever it may be
what are some core values that that you
now looking back
see our foundation for who you are that
we should take with us as well
i think one of the one of the most
important elements
for all of us is balance
it's this question that we talked about
a few minutes ago michael
where we have to have
a a life that is not so stressful
that we are constantly battling our
inner demons about what
is the right thing to do what's the best
thing for us to do there's no one right
answer
and so to have whether it's mindfulness
and meditation or
or hardcore exercise out on a bike for a
couple of hours or
or a way for you to just make sure that
you stay in touch with who you are and
what's important to you
that to me is a key element of any
successful person
and i have to say that that is that you
know as a young entrepreneur
and you know going through and
especially here in the bay area it it
the lines get blurred and and it's very
easy to all of a sudden find yourself
working in those 17 18 hour days on
various projects and
without even having the time before
going to bed to sit down reflect on
what's important what are the priorities
and and that's definitely something that
i'm taking to heart as well so so thank
you for the inspiration
laura before we go i want to thank you
for your generosity and
for everything that you're doing but
also for your generosity with your time
here for
for this show i really appreciate it and
i would like to ask for three words that
you would use to describe yourself
or that gary would use to describe you
or anybody else that's worked with you
okay so uh i i think i think i will say
and i did not prepare you for this so
i'm not holding those three words
i didn't give enough time ahead i i
guess
you know i care a lot so i'm caring
i'm highly energetic
and i'm passionate as you can tell of
course i love it
laura thank you very much i look forward
to continue watching
the amazing things that you're doing and
and thank you for all the inspiration
bye